Sudan's Army tells Al Jazeera the rapid
support forces launched an attack on the
general command of the central army late
on Thursday Muhammad Val is in Port
Sudan joins us from there so Muhammad
it's been a while since we heard of an
attack on the Central Command
tell us how that went down
yes Sami this has been a major
development because what we have been
watching over the last several weeks was
a routine daily a bombardment attacks
clashes and so on and air air activity
air fighter jets but now the lsf after
about a month and a half of giving up or
seemingly giving up on trying to take
the general command of the Sudanese army
they mounted a major attack during the
night the Sudanese Army commented by
saying it was a suicidal attempt and
that they have lost heavily
and they were repelled but it it it's it
can be seen in the context of the
of the media war between the two sides
because the the pro-military media has
been saying that to look the rsf has now
been destroyed has been all but
destroyed and reduced considerably they
can't Mount Major attacks they are going
to be finished very soon so this could
be a response According to some analysts
that the lsati is trying to send a
message through this attack they were
not hoping to be able to take the the
general command headquarters but it's a
message to say that we still have the
initiative we still have the ability to
attack and so on we saw some of this
this type of activities more than a week
ago when they tried to take the police
Reserve headquarters they took it for a
while but they sustained a lot of of
deaths and injuries and the Sudanese
Army now saying that you know they have
the upper hand they are using more
drones and they can contain the
situation very soon the other major
development which is of deep concern to
people here is what's going on in colder
fan and Darfur what looks like an
expansion of the conflict and also also
taking a kind of tribal Dimension there
because rsf has been attacking the
Sudanese Army in the uh the region of
which is in north cordovan and also
yesterday a major the amount of the
major attack against the Sudanese Army
in southern Darfur and they have been
talking about the tribal element in this
because there is a general National
mobilization in the country now to
support the Sudanese army they are
recruiting civilians and training them
to join the Army and rsf is being you
know very sensitive about this saying
that if you turn it into a tribal
conflict we also have our tribes and we
can call them and this is why many
people are fearing that this conflict
might very soon turn into a civil war
thanks so much Muhammad Val